I cannot in his King Tut's father
Akhenaten he got in big trouble because
when you go to Egypt if you if you ever
notice all those chipped away Gods all
those people are chipped away all their
faces that was under the order Akhenaten
he was kicked out of Egypt and when he
left Egypt he went to the to the Great
Pyramid and he went to that stone box
area inside the king chamber and took
the Ark of the Covenant with him see
Akhenaten is Moses that's the Moses
story he takes that with him he flees
with all his new followers with the Ark
of the Covenant and that's why the
powers that be sent an army after him
they're like you took the source of our
power with you we gotta have that and
they fled after him he never crossed the
Red Sea he crossed the Sea of reeds
which is a closer much smaller sea
around that same time frame that this
happened there was a massive earthquake
and a tsunami estimated to be in that
region which means it would have sucked
all the water out and would have come
crashing back